ترى أن هذه اللوحات فارغة
نعم وآمل أن يفرغوا
إلى الأبد فقط هؤلاء الرجال هؤلاء
هم الأشخاص الذين فقدوا حياتهم بالفعل
ويمكن ملء هذا قريبًا ، هذا هو
التهديد الحقيقي الذي تواجه أوكرانيا الآن
المزيد من الجنود الذين يموتون في معارك مع
يخبرني شيء ما
عينه وزير الدفاع الجديد في البلاد قبل شهر واحد فقط
أنه يكافح في
روسيا ، سيكون لديهم أيضًا نفس
الأماكن لسبب القول إن
الروس سيموتون أو ما
يسميه الكرملين
تدريبات الشتاء
المعتادة التي يقولها الكرملين هناك.  يوجد الآن حوالي
95000 جندي روسي على
مسافة قريبة ، تشير المعلومات الاستخبارية إلى أن ذلك
سيرتفع إلى 175000
ولكن حتى أن وزير الدفاع
أخبرني أنه أقل من التقدير
175 ، فلا يكفي
الذهاب إلى أوكرانيا ، فأنت تعتقد أن روسيا
ستحتاج إلى مزيد من
اليقين إلى أي
مدى غير واضح
لكن صور الأقمار الصناعية الأخيرة هذه من
روسيا تشير إلى أن موسكو منخرطة الآن في
بناء غير مسبوق بالقرب من
الحدود الأوكرانية بما يكفي  شن
غزو ساحق
يزعج الولايات المتحدة وحلف شمال الأطلسي
على الرغم من أن المسؤولين الأوكرانيين يبدون
هادئين فيما يبدو وكأنه تهديد وشيك ، إلا
أنني أود أن أقول إن الوسائل المختلفة تعني
أننا لسنا في حالة مزاجية من الخوف ،
لذلك لا يمكننا أن نمتلك أي فرصة لأن نكون
في هذا
الاتجاه.  هذا ولكنك لست خائفًا
من غزو روسي ،
لأنك لا تصدق المخابرات لا لا
لا لا تترك روسيا ، نعتقد في
معلوماتنا أننا نؤمن بكل الحقائق التي تم
إصلاحها من قبل
المخابرات الأمريكية وما إلى ذلك ولكن هل أنت كذلك؟
أعتقد أن هذا ليس القرار الأخير ،
هل تعتقد أن روسيا ستغزو
أه ، أنا لا أعتقد
أنني لن أصدق أن روسيا ستحقق
انتصارًا في أوكرانيا ، فهذا أمر
مختلف
لأنه سيكون مذبحة دموية حقًا وسوف يفعل
الرجال الروس أيضًا  العودة
إلى جوهر
[الموسيقى]
التي يمكن لروسيا التي تنكر وجود خطط للغزو
أن تردع بمساعدة الولايات
المتحدة وحلفائها.
في الجزء البحري الأوكراني من
برنامج تحديث عسكري أوسع بكثير
تحاول أوكرانيا تنفيذه
بدعم من الغرب ، الأمر الذي أثار غضب
العلاقات المتزايدة بين موسكو
وحلف الناتو والكرملين ، ومن المقرر أن تهيمن على
القمة الافتراضية للرئيس بايدن مع فلاديمير بوتين.  من
روسيا يوم الثلاثاء
وهو اجتماع مهم على الإنترنت يمكن أن
يحدد مصير أوكرانيا ، قال
لي الرئيس الأمريكي وزير الدفاع إنه يجب مضاعفة
دعم أوكرانيا
إذا كان بإمكاني تقديم المشورة للرئيس بايدن ، من
فضلك ، أود أن أطلب منه
توضيح ذلك بشكل مفهوم للغاية للسيد بوتين
لا توجد
خطوط حمراء من جانب الكرملين يمكن أن تكون
هنا الأسد الأحمر هنا في أوكرانيا
وسوف يتفاعل العالم المتحضر
دون
أي تردد ، لسنا بحاجة إلى
الجنود الأمريكيين أو الكنديين هنا
للقتال من أجل أوكرانيا ،
سنقاتل بأنفسنا ولكننا بحاجة إلى
تحديث الأسلحة نحن  هل نحتاج إلى
حرب إلكترونية وما إلى ذلك ، وقالت
المشكلة مع أمريكا وحلف شمال
الأطلسي وغيرها  إن
مساعدتهم لأوكرانيا تتمثل في أنه من
المحتمل أن يستفز الكرملين إلى
أبعد من ذلك ، بل إنه قد يؤدي إلى دس الدب
وإجبارهم على الغزو ، وهو ما
يثير قلقك ، هل تعتقد أن هذا أمر
واقعي ، فكرة عدم استفزاز
الإرادة الروسية  لا أعمل ،
أنا متأكد من
السبب
لأن جورجيا
سالزبوري القرم ، لذلك تعتقد أن
المواجهة مع روسيا هي
الطريقة الوحيدة لوقف النشاط الخبيث لروسيا
حول العالم ، آه لا يمكن أن تكون
المواجهة فقط ، بل يمكن
أن يكون موقفًا قويًا للغاية
نحن  شركاء أوكرانيا سوف
نساعدهم بكل الطرق للقيام بذلك
وسوف يسمع الكرملين ذلك
وسوف يتفهم ذلك
وسيتوقف أنا متأكد من
أنه مقامرة عالية المخاطر ولا يوجد
ضمان مثل هذا الخط المتشدد من
البيت الأبيض للكرملين سيفعل
أي شيء لإجبار روسيا على العودة